what is going on everybody welcome to
part 17 oh my gosh everything is really
degraded at this point now not even
copying and pasting he's just going over
the text-based version of the tutorial
okay so this one I just kind of want to
talk about where we stand now with the
training and the results and all of that
up to this point and what I think should
happen moving forward so so so basically
if you go to the text-based version of
this tutorial this is the script for
actually training the model I tried many
different models different setups and I
ended up kind of going with the same one
as what I had before and the only
difference in this script is the
difference different number of choices
on the output layer so there's really
not much different in this one we've
kind of already gone through you know
how to set all this stuff up
also let me think here this one doesn't
appear so yeah this one doesn't have the
out-of-sample data so I'm gonna go ahead
and host that as well I'm gonna edit
this text based version it's tutorials I
was a major issue so I did train this
model to about 40% accuracy but that's
like in sample accuracy and even the
validation accuracy we talked about that
before but it wasn't really validation
it wasn't like an ad a sample set so
what I did was I created a true
out-of-sample set and found out it's
just it's not actually that great so
just for the record random with you know
14 choices is not 0.14 it's actually you
should be like point seven one four I
think so that's an error anyways moving
along and then this is to actually run
the model and again I ran I think maybe
like 30 40 some games and I didn't be
easy once so that's not an improvement
over random I definitely be easy more
than that on random which is unfortunate
because the the first one like the one
that just made the attack choices that
actually did in
it beat it beat easy more than random
beat easy and then so the objective was
to eventually you know compete against
medium and then train a model on that
medium and then with that model compete
against hard all you need is like a
victory once in a great while to create
your training data but unfortunately we
don't have any so can't can't do
anything with that so so what I'd like
to talk about is like like for example
in the actual data creation I guess we
didn't actually go over the choices let
me see here because I did I did change
let's see if it's on this one and I just
didn't talk about it
right it is so I don't think I mentioned
anything on this let me see if I can get
this to pop over come on CSS you can do
it yeah alright so what I did here is in
the do something method so this is again
to create training data is I added in
these like weights so like for example
we weren't producing nearly enough
workers when the when it's just random
and everything's weighted the same so
what I did is we now we make a random
dot choice of choice weights and choice
weights is one times however many we
want basically you just have an eight
times chance to get workers versus you
know a 3x chance to get Z a lot and then
zel it and then zero I forget what the
zeroeth choices does that expand I
forget which no build Scout we just in
haven't you have to build Scout that
often so I think that's probably why I
didn't find that to be an issue anyway
you can keep adjusting these weights too
to build better training data
now when the model is done when the
neural network model is completed when
you actually go to run and test the
model so this is a let's see oh this is
the out-of-sample testing okay good I'm
glad I attached that so it did attach
that I will host the both training data
and out-of-sample data though for people
who want to
work with it okay so yeah in self-taught
use model we can basically do the exact
same thing so all we need to do is
create a weights vector and multiply the
weights vector by the you know the
output array from the neural network now
if we do that we can begin to kind of
tweak how that model performs but it
would be very important that you the
weights that you apply you would have to
still be you done you can't just make
some victories and call it a day you
would have to be still better than
random but then also as you keep
tweaking this it starts to like I don't
really mind tweaking a couple of things
because it's not working the greatest
but when you would like to really start
digging in and tweaking these weights
you're converting the AI to be more
rule-based and I really want to avoid
that especially in the early stages that
we're in right now I don't want to do it
so anyways but regardless through quite
a bit of tweaking I still could not get
it to do better than just the random
model with the weights and again the
random model with the weights to create
the initial training data isn't as big
of a sin as you know trying to get this
model to do well by heavily weighting it
at the end and like I said I couldn't
beat it if you could wait it and you
could beat it then all you got to do is
okay use that as training data and just
keep iterating on that process and that
could produce the results unfortunately
I just couldn't it doesn't beat even the
easy AI which is problematic so what to
do from here I mean there's a whole
bunch of things one is unfortunately
don't actually have the real image what
I could do though is I can log in to the
actual paper space oh I'm worried let's
see so and I can pull that up and the
machines already on too and I can show
you the training data because it's it's
not it's not good enough so a part of me
thinks right now the issue is mostly
like the the actual model itself I think
we could come up with probably something
better
experiencing some serious lag here okay
here we go okay so this is the tensor
board of the train data I'll turn on
relative and this actually might be you
know these are two separate models okay
great
so so these were just two attempts at
using true out-of-sample data and it for
the validation that is and as you can
see it's not it's not going so hot we're
not even really beating random here
which is super super unfortunate with
enough epochs we do actually begin to
get accuracy will go up the problem is
validation accuracy does not so you know
looking at this I would just say either
the data is no good or the model is no
good we're just not fitting this data so
I mean there's like an infinite
combination of models that we could try
so that's kind of my next step is just
to keep trying a bunch of different
models and see does anything train if
not then we need to probably reconsider
maybe going back to the color method you
know using multiple different colors
revisiting that kind of drawing and all
that because it's really crazy though
because like when I run this model I can
see it knows how and knows how to do
stuff like for example like when we
start when we get under attack that's
you'll start seeing defend Nexus like it
starts coming through and you don't see
that other times right so it's
definitely like picking something up it
just doesn't seem to be good enough so
anyways kind of stuck at the moment to
be honest so I'm gonna upload the data
anyways you guys can play with it I
think the biggest thing is just fitting
to the data I will upload the model to
the model that I have up to this point
if someone wants to try to play with
weights but I don't think you'll get
anywhere but it is interesting I mean
it's definitely over fit but the
validation accuracy is you know neutral
I mean is it's really no different than
random so no no real surprise there I
guess yeah so anyways that's all for now
if I I'm gonna keep working on it but if
until I find like a better
Ellucian either to better data or
whatever a model that trains on
basically fourteen or like something
like this I probably won't produce an
update and it just takes a long long
time like this at least right now these
two models you know I spent a few days
on but the model previously was like
days in days like four days or something
like that let me see if it's up here
here it would be yeah so from the 21st
to the 24th I trained that model so
anyways it just takes a long time it's
kind of like the GTA series so anyways
if I come up with any sort of update I
will let you guys know if you find
something that trains awesome if you
think you have an idea for a way that we
can work with the model and get it to
work you know let me know below anyway
that is all for now hopefully that will
be the last time I say anyways and if
you got questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
otherwise I will see you in the next
anyways